i mean that's that's what is so
mind-blowing about
this 85 south i i don't know you call it
a show it's like a movement it's like a
revolution like
the impact that 85 south is making
not just on the comedy game but like
entertainment it's like unfounded what
you guys are achieving and i've talked
to chad the producer and
carlos and clayton like what is your
take on
85 south and why it is having the impact
that it has
uh one because it's genuine this is a
genuine relationship
that we have like fly came in uh
what two seasons after we came in but he
fit right in and and just when we
communicated
with each other it was just always
genuine
so that's the basis of it okay but one
of the major things that i think
it is we're in the hotel lobby right now
we are in the hotel
this is the mud this is the come up this
is the the way we're in the hotel they
excited
you know you guys went from like the
studios to the trap
to you know and that's the thing like
the only way that that can happen is
just if it's genuine you
have to be excited about going to do
whatever it is you're going to do yeah
and one of the major things i think that
makes what we do a little different is
that
we all hold our own
in our own right i got shows in atlanta
this weekend
dc was in pittsburgh last week i mean
just yesterday carlos is in cincinnati
ohio headlining the funny bone all
weekend so we all
do what we do individually but we come
together
and get on stage together
you know kings of comedy is a legendary
movie but could you imagine if we got to
sort
got to see dl you know i mean said
bernie and steve come out together and
talk
[ __ ] together that's a whole nother
movie right you know so i think that's
really what gives people the different
feel you've never seen it
done that way before and it's
all improv it should be magic to us too
like we don't practice
anything we get on stage and we go you
know i mean we got my man craig right
here
yeah we're gonna attest to that we never
sit around and have no meetings about
all right bro
we in this city so that's what we got
none of that because it's so genuine and
like i said that energy that i was
talking about
is so strong and it's so genuine that
when we get on stage it's literally
magic so i think that most people
can see that and even the people who may
have
negative opinions about what we do
because you know you see all of that
it doesn't that doesn't matter you know
what i mean because
that is the same type of effect that the
positive energy has
even though you don't like it it's
affected you some type of way
and what it is that we do has made you
feel real emotion
so that means it's something special i
heard somebody say that martin wasn't
funny the other day
i looked at him like they was crazy but
he was able to sit and have a
conversation to me as to why he didn't
which means you watched it long enough
to develop the opinion that you had
so it really doesn't change in regards
to the what
i'm giving you or what what martin did
in regards to giving you that show
he gave it to you and because he gave it
to you he was able to formulate
something
that lasted for long after he stopped
doing it
and still have people having
conversations about it
right now and that's the type of energy
that we create with the 85
like god forbid if we was to stop
tomorrow
the things that we've done up until this
point i feel like will be talked about
for a long time because people haven't
even really
grasped the reality of it like to go
back and watch
like these guys are really doing
something completely different
so i just think that the reason why
we're able to
you know do what we do not necessarily
the success because that just came
organically but the reason why we're
able to do what we do
is because it was just based in a
genuine these are we brothers for real
right you know i mean we don't sit
around and talk about
work we talk about life you know what i
mean like we know each other's children
families i've been to these people's
house and hug their mothers and you know
what i mean like
all of us you know it's just a different
type of environment and for
us to be able to have that type of
brotherhood and still be able to get on
stage and share the light
it's amazing man and the 85 percenters
definitely reflect that
yeah they serious you know what i mean
like and in there it's it's in this
it's it's crazy to me because
you know all around is just a blessing
man
it's just a super blessing because like
i said like we've been talking about
this whole time my perspective is
different and losing's perspective is
different and fly's perspective is
different
so a lot of the things that will
probably cause
dissension or cause disruption amongst
this process
just doesn't affect us the same way i've
seen people you know we work in all
different types of environments
i've seen how opinions affect people
i've seen people really look at comments
that people leave
and be truly like deflated
right there's no way i can be deflated
about
anybody's opinion you are entitled to
your opinion
but i'm entitled not to give a [ __ ]
about it you know what i mean
and that's whether it be whatever it may
be
but none of us
allow what they say quote unquote
to affect what we do you know what i'm
saying i'm gonna be me
regardless of whether or not you like it
or not you don't have to like it
but until you decide to get up and do
something that's gonna stop me from
doing what i do
you're gonna have to just keep not
liking it but i've seen the people that
do like it
you guys are like the beatles out there
yeah i mean no it's that's it you have a
crazy
favorite story or anything the people
who do love it like
that's something no i i'd like to look
at life in regards to this
you don't have to know what you want you
just have to know what you don't want
and don't like so as long as you know
what you don't like
you're good the love you don't even have
to
like that goes without saying because
that isn't what somebody's going to need
motivation on so i don't even like to
even really discuss those type of things
because
you don't need no motivation on how to
deal with love but the
negative stuff and the hate that
comedians and entertainers get is what i
see deflate them so if
i can offer any type of perspective
it'll be based in that because the love
is the love you don't need no
preparation for love
love is love and whenever you get it you
gonna know it's love
i had a dude in the mall walk up on me
man literally chico
love you [ __ ] i love you i was like
appreciate you bro
i'm walking away hey love you [ __ ]
and it's like you don't have to prepare
for that you know what i mean that
doesn't take any preparation
because you're able to receive that
however you receive it but it's the
other stuff that you have to prepare
yourself for
the stuff that you don't want so once
you prepare yourself for the stuff that
you don't want
everything that you want just becomes
that much more magnified because the
things you don't want don't affect your
ability to recognize the things that you
do
and the the come up as we'll land this
plane here
one thing that helps comedians keep
perspective is like bombing on stage
and i ask every comedian on here like a
story of getting booed or like just an
unforgettable show they were just
everything went wrong
right like do you have one top of mind
and this is how crazy it happens for me
okay that's how unique i am as a human
being